[Music]
and today's lecture topic is
opportunities for the application of
quantitative models
uh before we start i just want to go
over the asking questions um
in policy today in today's event
so usually um we have these
speaking events in downtown berkeley the
auditorium uh opened white public
but uh since goldman uh i think this
might be the first um
into this uh wall
uh we do have a few people are joining
us on zoom as well
and uh
in the auditorium you can just raise
your hands i hope that's great for you
to talk and otherwise
please enter your questions in the q a
so this time talking to people
from the control panel and they'll
address as many questions as possible at
the end of the talk so we have some
lectures in your question and answer
session
um i am trafficking i'm the director of
the science institute there's a few
words about the institute uh given the
public nature of this lecture series
it's an international venue for
collaborative research
through science and science in 2012 with
a very generous grant from the science
foundation
and bring together uh world's leading
researchers intermediate computer
science and other skills to me
benefit from theoretical computer
science and vice versa and to explore
essentially the use of thinking and
science engineering medicine and
studying the laws of communication
itself
and one of the explicit goals of the
institute is to expand the horizons of
the field by exploring other scientific
disciplines uh through social
algorithmic and scientific in
computational lenses and the insights uh
made from such explanations often relate
back to the field itself
in today's lecture there's a great
example there
um
and
our english speakers
are nom a balder and noah holds an md
from template university a phd in public
health and computer science from bengal
university in the bachelor of science
and computer science from the open
university in israel and he completed
his postdoc in the public health and
following biomedical informatics at um
actually former biomedical informatics
in harvard medical school and he's the
head of the real world evidence research
and innovations lab at tennessee
hospital in israel medical center it's
actually largest israeli hospital and
cohen's digital health care laboratory
in the department of software and
information system engineering at bengal
university
is the director of the ai driven
medicine department
innovation she tells about the reduction
of the talk the lead research institute
and she cohesive
in the department of software and
information system engineering at bengal
university
and um
but in any case uh health insurance in
israel is mandatory as people might know
and
it's very comprehensive and it's messed
up for services and uh
it's one of the
hmos
hmo and has a tremendous amount of data
and very
innovative encounters using this data so
i'm
looking forward to your talk
please
so we'll keep a brisk pace it should be
fine because it's not a very messy
lecture
so
this is the promise the premise is
that significant significant
advancements are being made in
computational methods that could be
beneficial to healthcare some of which
we've seen over the last
few days but generally speaking it's
hard to bring these methods to bear
there is a so-called implementation gap
of which much has been
said and a lot of this gap stems from
needing
very specific circumstances to bring
these algorithmic advances
to bear we
will aim to show
that a fully integrated healthcare
system is well positioned to take
advantage of a computational tools to
benefit healthcare and we will do so by
just showing
certain recent
achievements that were made in the
fields of causal influence and
predictive modelling over the last
two years in israel
so this is the outline of the talk i'll
start by talking about uh
the data which uh we'll be using and the
healthcare system in israel in general
then i'll talk about
informing medical knowledge through
cultural influence and then now i will
carry on with a predictive modeling
okay so let's start with the
israeli health care system in israel
health insurance is mandatory it's been
that way since 1995
everyone every permanent resident is
eligible for a very wide and generous
uh services basket that's how it's
called it's not tied to payment so you
can avoid paying your medical bills the
government will come after you to
collect the money they hold but you'll
keep getting a
health care it's provided by four per
provider
health organizations which are called
that's just how they're called sick
funds that's our hmo
and individuals can just switch freely
between the different
sick funds there is no
discretion they have to accept everyone
but in reality few people do actually
chain
most people just stick to the
sick fact
of these health organizations klalit
which is the one we'll be discussing
today is the largest it ensures 52
percent of the israeli population then
there's maccabi and two others and these
health organizations are not pure
insurers like
most american health organizations
rather they are mostly providers they
directly provide most of the services
they have to so they directly provide
primary care specialists care labs
imaging them drugs and usually
indirectly provide hospitalization
thanks to some smart people that were in
office about 20 years ago
israeli healthcare has been digitalized
for a long time and this gives us very
good longitudinal data all of the health
organizations pull all of their data
into large data lakes that seamlessly
connect all the different facets of a
person's healthcare and each person has
a single unique identifier so there's no
siloing it's all
uh
together with one another and it's also
interfaced with governmental system so
things like demographics which the sikh
funds are not generally aware of rather
the government is the information is
shared with the sequence by the
government on a day-to-day basis so as
we'll see much further down the talk
this allows the sig funds for example to
be able to map family relationships
throughout israel because we know
everyone's parents we know everyone's
sibling everyone's children
clinic health services which is the one
we'll be specifically talking about
today because this is the data that was
used for all of this research is the
loudest one it has 4.7 million in show
patient historically even more than
other six months it directly provides
most of its services so it buys less and
directly provides more and it also owns
hospitals so
it doesn't buy services it also but
it also directly provides
hospitalization services
so
the last
facet is
the kobe 19 data because we'll be
focusing a lot on on the kobe 19
pandemic israel was unique in being
very early to mass vaccinate i think the
first in the world by late
2020 and it was the first to provide
boosters it used almost exclusively the
physical vaccine very little moderna
and all the information is was and is
collected centrally by the ministry of
health so
things like who gets vaccinated who gets
tested who's positive who dies
because of kovic 19 who gets
hospitalized that's all collected
centrally by the ministry of health and
shared with the different health funds
so
all of that was
the integrated healthcare part of of the
title
me trying to
make you understand how this
amazing data that i'm about to show you
is collected but let's let's start with
the scientific part so i'll be talking
about how
we made use of this data to inform
medical knowledge through a causal
inference
when the copy 19 pandemic broke out and
and even more so once vaccines started
in in late 2020 suddenly there was
and there were a lot of causal questions
that needed
very quick answers so
all of us everyone the medical community
the scientific community but generally
everyone
needed to
know
to get answers about the effectiveness
of vaccines direct and indirect i'll
explain these
terms later we needed to know if the
vaccines are safe
we needed to know the answers to all
these questions for children for
pregnant women and for other
subgroups we very quickly had questions
about waning immunity from the vaccines
we had novel variants still have
regrettably novel variants uh which we
needed the answers for
and more and more
in medicine
specifically but also elsewhere when
there are causal questions the first
line to answering them is randomized
clinical trials
randomized clinical trials which as
their names suggest for those not
familiar are
a
controlled experiment interventions in
which the researcher controls the
assignment of treatment and it does so
using randomization so who get for
example in vaccination who gets
vaccinated who doesn't
that's something that is randomized
that's the first line or we use to um
estimate causal effects it's it's a
great instrument it's our most valid
instrument for estimating a causal
effect but rcts also have distinct
disadvantages generally speaking they
are very expensive they are slow to
conduct
they usually have small sample sizes
that limit their usefulness they are
usually done with highly selected
populations for good reasons all of
these things has very good reasons but
it's still
a limitation and they are not always
ethically feasible generally speaking
very often during the pandemic rcts
couldn't keep up
we had questions that needed answering
but we didn't we couldn't get those
answers from a randomized clinical
trials
that's when observational studies
studies come to the risk so observation
of studies are
studies that are based on data in which
the researcher doesn't get to control
the treatment assignment people do as
they do
and from that we need to
estimate causal
effects this makes identification of the
causal effects hub we'll discuss this
in a second and as
i'll try to show you
you can only really do it successfully
with very very high quality
date
the kind that that integrated healthcare
systems genera
even more so
during the pandemic we needed answers
about subgroup effects so rcts generally
because of those small sample sizes
estimate an average treatment effect
over the entire sample and that average
treatment effect is assumed by necessity
to apply to everyone it's all we have so
we we just assume it applies to everyone
this of course is fine if there isn't a
lot of heterogeneity but as we'll see in
one particular example heterogeneity
does exist
uh in medicine and the average treatment
effects are just not enough
observational studies on the other hand
have to work very hard for validity but
have to get get subgroup effects mostly
free because the sample sizes are
usually very very large can be in the
millions and if you do have valid sub
group effects then you can make
personalized decisions for people which
of course is a great
uh great something to have
okay so
i i now need to prove to you if you
don't yet believe it that causal
influence for observational data is hard
it's sufficiently hard to necessitate
having amazing data to do it validly so
why is it hard and i'll explain all of
this with no math notation and no
philosophy usually at this point
david hume would be
quoted quite extensively in a causal
interest course but we'll do none of
that so what is a causal effect a causal
effect is a contrast of counter
fractures of potential outcomes for
example
looking at myself it's what would happen
to me if i were to get vaccinated versus
what would happen to me if i wouldn't
get vaccinated by definition if we if we
look at the binary case only one of
those can ever be observed either i get
vaccinated or i don't get vaccinated
that would mean the other one is
counterfactual it's counter to fat
in real life what we can observe
is just what happens
by chance so just the people who happen
to get vaccinated and the people who
happen not to get vaccinated making the
jump from this which is
as you can understand not causal
to the um to the causal effects is the
domain of what's called causal
identification causal identification
relies on certain assumptions that are
not easily met in a observational study
so let's talk about these assumptions
and then dive deeper into the first one
so the first assumption and usually the
one talked about the most is
exchangeability or ignorability
to put it plainly it means that the
study groups are comparable they're
comparable in regard to their
potential outcomes now just think about
that for a second obviously with
observational data that's not going to
be true people make they self select
they make the decision to be treated or
their physician makes the decision for
them because of reasons reasons that
have to be
related to their potential outcomes
it doesn't have
this assumption doesn't have to be met
marginally for the entire population uh
we can still do causal inference if the
assumption is met conditionally for
after having condition on some set of
variables so for example it might be
that we treat the elderly more but once
we condition on age then treatment
assignment within the stratum within the
start of age is
random that's good enough for us and as
we'll see that's basically the the
the basis of causal incidents from
observational data the second assumption
is positivity positivity means that for
each
stratum defined by the variables from
the previous bullet we have a positive
probability of being
of receiving all the treatment levels so
for example looking at age the elderly
some of them do get vaccinated and some
of them do not get vaccinated otherwise
how are we going to do the causal
contrast we need
both sides
the third assumption is no hidden
variations of treatment it means that
the potential outcome is is a
well-defined
something so in the
regard to vaccination it would mean that
receiving the vaccination leads to a
single specific potential outcomes and
it doesn't depend on whether you were
injected here or here or if the coaching
was met or who gave the injection etc
the last assumption and we're going to
have some fun with it with this one is
no interference no interference means
that my potential outcome only depends
on my treatment assignment so whether or
not i have a myocardial infarction a
heart attack only depends on whether i
take a cholesterol medication that works
well with cholesterol medication doesn't
work very well with vaccinations which
protect me but also protect my
uh surroundings
so this is an assumption as as we'll see
it actually provides some opportunity
our cities have it easy have it easy in
in regard to the assumptions
exchangeability is met thanks to
randomization and any violation is by
definition if randomization was carried
out successfully something that is
random and can be quantified using
statistical tools so exchangeability is
met positivity is true by design the
protocol ensures that
everyone
some people do get the treatment some
don't hidden variations of treatment are
avoided by having very strict protocols
that control how the treatment is
they're provided
and interference is avoided by the small
sample sizes and by the protocol that
says that for example you don't
vaccinate two people within the same
household or within the same school or
whatever is needed for this to be met
now i had to put this disclaimer here
because this is going on youtube that
our cities don't really have it easy our
cities are hard to conduct they're
expensive they require amazing
statistical expertise and and they do
have
serious threats to their validity that
need to be maintained but they do have
it easy for the for a causal
identification assumption observational
studies on the other hand need to try
harder much much harder we want
exchangeability we have to have
exchangeability we need to identify
using domain expertise a sufficient set
of confounders to condition on
we'll talk about that more in a second
positivity it might simply not exist it
is entirely possible that in a certain
stratum everyone was treated or everyone
wasn't treated and then you have a
problem restrict your study or you know
go do something else
no hidden variations of treatment
requires precisely defining the
treatment you're looking at and and
hopefully
you know you have enough data
to um to enforce that and no
interference also a problem specifically
with vaccinations and it needs to be
accounted for let's see specifically for
exchangeability how we had to handle it
in copy 19
trials so this is an example a classic
example of confounding of a spurious
correlation if we just look at the
renault variables ice scheme cells and
shark attacks we would see that they are
of course correlated but obviously
there's no causal connection we stopped
selling ice cream sharks aren't going to
stop eating people it's all because of
summer time summertime causes ice cream
cells and summertime causes a shark it
makes so basically we need all of those
or at least we need a sufficient set of
those
to condition on to ensure
exchangeability
there is probably no data-driven way to
find a sufficient set of confounders it
can only occur by domain expertise so
before you even look at the data you
make a cup of coffee you sit in a dark
room and you think you think what causes
the exposure and also causes the outcome
i'm being pretty simplistic but it's
sufficient for our
purposes so we needed what causes
vaccination because we want to study the
the effect of vaccination on covenant
again what causes vaccination and also
causes uh infection disability and
mortality and
we had a lot of information at this
point
we knew that the vaccinated are very
different than the non-vaccinated they
are different in demographics they're
different in geographic they are
different in their baseline health
status and we know that all of these
things are also
connected to the outcomes moreover we
knew that these things were changing
over time and i'll prove that in a
second using graphs
so we
knew that there were big differences in
age groups
in regard to vaccination some of those
by design because the government was
targeting vaccinations at the first
stage to the more elderly we knew that
there were differences by age group with
regard to vaccination
we knew and this is this is a sad slide
that regrettably is still pretty true
the socioeconomic status determines both
the rate of vaccination and also the
rate of infections so socioeconomic
status is then a clear confounder for
which we will have to adjust
while all of this was happening there
were societal interventions happening
schools were being shut down and
reopened people were being put under
lockdown and and lockdowns were ending
so calendar time is a very very clear
confounder that we would have to adjust
for
so
we thought about this long and hard and
eventually we came up with this list of
potential
confounders for which we need to adjust
now again i'm emphasizing this happened
before we looked at the data so it is
entirely possible with observational
studies that you would think you would
come up with a list of confounders and
you will discover that you don't measure
them you don't have them in your data
set and either you will find a new
identification strategy there are
quite a bit but you either they exist or
they don't or you you give up on the
tile and you hope someone else does it
better so this is where the the amazing
data from clelit
really shown because we had all of these
things observed we could either adjust
for them or in the specific
circumstances when there was still there
was still a lot of variability even
after adjusting for them we could
exclude uh based on uh some of them
so our first task for ensuring
exchangeability which is
identifying a sufficient set of
confounders
is over we found a sufficient set but
now you need to adjust for them somehow
and adjusting is not a trivial it's
something that requires modeling or
some other tactic there's a bunch of
ways none of them is better than others
they all have their advantages and
disadvantages in those probability
waiting coverage adjustment matching etc
we chose matching so for each vaccinated
person we matched a very similar
non-vaccinated person matching is not
usually the go-to
adjustment method but we opted for
matching because
because of several reasons well first
it's it's technically hard to
parametrically model very high
dimensional variables such as the
neighborhood in which a person lives
that was on the list of confounders and
it's it's how to model calendar
parametrically matching kind of takes
care of that
we
very much wanted to
stay close to the data so we didn't want
to have to rely on parametric models
which could very well be black box
models
which
you know adds another assumption now you
have all of the causal assumptions and
you have another model that needs to be
accurate otherwise it doesn't work so
that was another one and the third
reason is we really wanted these pretty
graphs it sounds like a weird reason to
have but this
this
figure is not from us it's from the
pfizer
phase 3 trial and it was everywhere at
the time and rightfully so because this
shows very nicely the separation between
the non-vaccinated and the vaccinated
and we knew that we needed this we
needed a figure such as this to persuade
people that the vaccine works in the
real world setting
okay so we decided we want to create a
matched cohort but how do you go about
creating a menstrual that's also not
trivia
well maybe it is trivial let's just take
people who got vaccinated and people who
didn't get vaccinated and match them one
against the other well this this this
doesn't work this is not allowed because
this involves speaking into the future
if you only allow a person to be matched
as unvaccinated if he never gets
vaccinated that means you'll always be
looking into his future to make sure he
doesn't get vaccinated this causes
selection binds
instead what you need to do is you need
to think like you were doing a
randomized clinical flight you need to
think okay if i was doing an rct how
would it look well i'll have a
vaccinated and at the same day without
knowing what's going to happen tomorrow
we need to mention unvaccinated to him
and then on and on and on and on the
problem with this obviously is that some
of our unvaccinated are going to break
protocol this is retrospective data they
ain't they don't know that i'm going to
recruit them to a trial it's going to be
held in three months as an unvaccinated
some of them are going to be vaccinated
the next day
uh so they break protocol and what do i
do now i have two problems one is that
they are no longer eligible to be
controlled because they are vaccinated
the second is i lost exchangeability
because this guy with his specific age
specific sex a specific socio-economic
status doesn't have a matched control so
what we opted to do is to
sensor this guy's data the vaccinated
data because he doesn't have a control
but to let the unvaccinated the person
who is now vaccinated rejoin the study
as a vaccinator hopefully with a new
uh
unvaccinated control and this of course
can recur over and over and over because
the controls can always then
be vaccinated but there is no other way
it's it's the only way to do it you need
this day-to-day uh follow-up
okay
last question about exchangeability we
did all of this we were pretty proud of
ourselves we thought of confounders we
did this fancy match code how do we know
it worked
well the short answer is we can't just
like you can't let the data choose your
confounders the data doesn't tell you
that there are no more confounders left
the longer answer is that we can't prove
it but we can disprove it by identifying
negative controls in this specific
example negative control outcomes which
are outcomes that are known not to be
affected by the exposure so the vaccine
doesn't affect them but they are
plausibly affected by the same set of
confounders if we then not see a null
effect for these negative controls we
know we have a problem
but thinking about negative controls is
just as hard as thinking about
confounders i mean
it can only happen by domain expertise
luckily vaccines have
one such perfect negative controls and
that's the first 10 days after
vaccination we know that the vaccine
only kicks in after 10 to 12 days so if
we see anything happening in the first
days
that would mean we are biased we have
residual confounding
and we use that and as you can see from
this graph and you will see later it it
was pretty good news okay so
i hope i managed to prove to you that
causal influence for observational
real-world data is hard
now i'll i'll
shift topic and having done all of this
having built this
study design let's see some specific
causal questions and answers
which we answered over the course of
depending so the first one is what we
started with real world vaccine
effectiveness so we knew from the phase
three clinical trial by pfizer that the
vaccine is very efficacious but the rcts
are very tightly controlled will the
vaccine hold up in a real world setting
well
it did it actually did so wonderfully
for all five
outcomes which we examined infection
hospitalization severe disease and that
the vaccine was very very effective
er starting from
about day 14 and even more so
after the second dose but remember i
said we care about subgroup effects this
is one of the advantages of
observational studies we know that
specific vaccines are not so effective
among the elderly is this also true for
the covet 19 physical vaccine it's not
we found that the vaccine is effective
for all age groups
sadly this didn't hold up as well for
people with multi-comorbidity
specifically comorbidities relating to
the kidney
but also
others this is the kind of information
you can really only get from
observational studies because you will
never have the sample size in an lcd
to do it second question pregnancy
pregnant women are excluded from our cts
generally because of ethical reasons and
and other reasons but we knew at this
point that pregnant women were at
specifically high risk for seville
coveted 19.
so what do we recommend should they get
the vaccine shouldn't they is the
vaccine effective
well thankfully we could do this
observational trial and we found that
the vaccine is very very effective for
pregnant women and indeed thanks to this
evidence and others the vaccine is very
much recommended for
pregnant women third question it's nice
that the vaccine is effective for adults
against the wild type the original
variant but
pretty soon we had the delta variant all
over the world and we were vaccinating
adolescence is the vaccine still
effective in this group against this new
variant
now i can tell you a year later that for
example against omicron the vaccine is
not as effective but is it against delta
well we found that it is the physical
vaccine is effective against the delta
variant this was
very good news because at this point in
time the delta variant was
doing a lot of damage
worldwide so we showed that the vaccine
is safe but is it
we show that it's effective but is it
safe
safety is a particular weakness for
randomized clinical trials because a lot
of safety signals are pretty rare and
our cities rarely go above a few hundred
thousand often you need millions to
identify the rare side effects we had
millions
and we could do this we could study
about 30 something side effects and we
could show that the vaccine is
safe for the majority of them we found
two big signals one is lymphadenopathy
the enlargement of lymph nodes which is
a mild
side effect and we found myocarditis an
infection of the heart muscle which
which i'll discuss a bit more in an
instant but this is only half the
question right so these are the threats
from the vaccine but
you take the vaccine so you don't get
sick with covered 19.
so the second thing we did is we
compared the risk from the vaccine with
the side effects from recovery 19
infection and we found that even for uh
diseases for which the vaccine causes
increased sleep such as myocarditis
being infected with cov19 is a lot worse
so
we could we could have a pretty complete
picture of the safety of the vaccine so
myocarditis is a serious disease
myocarditis in general it's an infection
of the heart muscle that could
potentially
be lethal we knew we needed to dive
deeper
into myocarditis and so we ran a
specific study with myocarditis it's
still a pretty real side effect so we
could only do it owing to the um to the
richness of the data that we had and we
found that microbiotics occurs mostly
after the second dose and
we specifically found this picture
miraculous is pretty real it's two for a
hundred thousand people but it's mostly
or almost exclusively in males and
within males it's almost exclusively in
young males so
thanks to this study and others then by
others we could
isolate we could limit the concern to a
specific specific specific
age group
boosters israel was the first to boost
before anyone else uh in the world
because israel was in the midst of a of
a very bad delta wave and the ministry
of decided very wisely to be brave and
to give boosters but there wasn't any
evidence at this point we we generated
the evidence among the first in the
world and we saw that the boosters were
very very very effective and i think
this shows it even better for each age
group for each caller the graph is the
incidence of a new infection and the
dashed vertical line is when that
specific age group became eligible for
the vaccine and you can see that for
each age group about a week after they
become eligible for the vaccine the
the line breaks and incidents begins to
fall the boosters
change the cause of the third pandemic
wave in israel probably a preventing
widespread death and maybe even
something that looked at some point like
imminent failure of the healthcare
system
all of this was about direct vaccination
the last thing i want to talk about
before handing
the stage over to noah is indirect
vaccine effect so direct vaccine effect
is the
the protection afforded to someone uh
being vaccinated
himself so if i get vaccinated it's the
protection i enjoy but vaccines a lot of
their magic is protecting others around
the people being vaccinated household
members people you live with so these
are indirect effects and they are
particularly important if you can't get
vaccinated for example if you are a
child under the age of vaccinate
vaccination if you are immunosuppressed
and the vaccine just doesn't work for
you
so
studying indirect effects is very very
important but it's also pretty hard
indirect effects generally happen by two
mechanisms
one is um
for example look at the person and his
children so you vaccinated the parent to
protect the children how does that work
well first the parent doesn't
get sick he doesn't get sick so he can't
infect the child the second mechanism is
that even if it does get infected the
vaccinated usually
transmit less
this is a cartoon we do to illustrate
that so how are the children protected
the parents either don't get infected to
begin with or if they get infected they
transmit less
studying indirect effects is hard
because we need to take account of a
person's community the people who he
exposes and who expose him but a
person's community is composed of his
family of his friends of his workplace
those are things that are usually not
visible to a researcher at all
this can only be studied in um
in systems where there is
really
very very rich interconnected data
we had this sort of data specifically
for households we knew from previous law
by
by by elizabeth
that we could study indirect effects by
just looking at households households
are a very important
um a lot of cognitive transmission
occurs within household so just just by
looking at the person's household we
could
study
the indirect effect now like i said at
the beginning click can draw a family
tree of all of its insult population and
families usually
aggregate to one sixth front so if the
child is in clearly the parent will
usually be included and vice versa so
this allowed us to study indirect
indirect effects within a household how
did we do it we took households that had
two parents and at least one child under
the age of a vaccination and we looked
at the infection rate of the children
as a function of how many parents were
vaccinated zero one parent or both
parents and we found that
we did this for two different periods
either an early period for the alpha
a variant or a later period for the
delta period and we found that
vaccinating both parents reduces the
rate of infection for the children by 70
percent of the early period and 60
for the late uh period
this was consistent across child's ages
so this was true for very young children
but also for adolescents and this was
consistent across
household sizes and this is
this is big news right
i have two children under the age of
vaccination i can protect them even
though they can't get vaccinated by the
virtue of me being vaccinated and my
wife being vaccinated i can lower the
probability of infection by 70
that's amazing if the vaccine alone did
70
just by virtue of the direct effect we
would be pleased and we can achieve that
with an indirect effect
this wasn't enough for us we wanted to
understand the mechanism like i said
earlier either the parent doesn't get
infected or it doesn't transmit which is
it the answer is it's both
so obviously we knew from the direct
effect that vaccinated parents get
infected a lot less the vaccine early
after the second dose is about 90
percent effective also after the boost
but we found that
vaccinated parents transmit a lot less
which is
very important because it means that
even if the infection manages to get
into the household there is still a
smaller probability that the children
are
affected so this is the
final result this was recently published
in science
and
this sums up everything i talked about
for the early period one last word well
semi one one as well that's privacy
privacy is the elephant in the room when
we discuss the amazing interconnected
data that
healthcare systems have it is a
simple axiom that maintaining patient
privacy is of the utmost
a concern i didn't talk about that
though it definitely deserves
uh discussing but you should know
as we discussed this that there are many
many layers of protection uh for
research like this conducted on on on
this kind of rich data in israel there
is there are institutional review boards
and there's anonymization etc etc so i i
felt this deserves some
talking about but we can talk about it
more offline if anyone
specifically won
so just before i hand over the stage the
interim the interim summary at this
point is that the pandemic is raising a
lot of causal questions answering these
questions our cts are
are not enough we need high quality data
that is extensive and immediate and that
the integrated structure of healthcare
systems is allowing such
research
questions
yeah we'll do it together in the end
um okay so
nom discussed how we can inform medical
knowledge and that is uh lots of times
done through uh quantitative models of
causal inference and i'll be talking
about how we actually
try to promote care to actual patients
through
prediction models that are aimed to do
predictive proactive and personalized
care um which is we think better than
the care we can provide today
so
first i need to convince you that we do
need to provide some better care than
than what we
can with the mids we have now
and
in order to do that i'll show you some
statistics
so first of all
some statistics
state that
because the the third cause of death in
in western countries and specifically in
the us is health care errors
it's it's not consistent across all
statistics statistics it's kind of
depends on how you calculate these uh
cause of death lists but some
mentioned this as a very major cause of
death
thirty percent of care that is given is
futile and has no net benefit so we want
to avoid it because it may do some harm
and 45 of the care that should be given
is not given
just to put some specific numbers
because these seem very high level
how do we compute such a percent like 45
percent so for
very specific examples only 66 percent
of patients with established
cardiovascular disease that means that
they already sustained something like a
heart attack
receive statins to lower their
cholesterol and they all should be given
this treatment
only 25 to 50 percent of hypertensive
patients achieve appropriate blood
pressure control
and only 30 of those with history of
osteoporotic factors actually receive
treatment to prevent the next fracture
and you should know that osteoporotic
fractures
may not seem like such a
dangerous outcome but
if you sustain specific fractures your
risk of dying in the next year is higher
than most types of cancer so it is
something we really want to prevent but
still only 30 percent are receiving the
right treatment
so we have a problem but but why if we
understand why maybe we can help solve
some of the problems
first problem is that
the information the in the medical
literature grows exponentially with time
so it is estimated
that in the 1950s
the medical literature basically doubled
over every 50 years so it means that
someone graduated from med school back
then
they were pretty much good for their
entire career
that changed over time gradually and it
was estimated that in 2010 the medical
literature doubled every four years so
now consider that med student that poor
med student that needs to
study
everything up to date what happens just
throughout the course of
his or her training
and it is now
estimated that the medical literature
grows or doubles every few months so
it's not all uh
like actively affecting
patients treatment some of it are a lot
of papers that are less relevant but the
relevant part
grows really really fast and no human
brain of any medical doctor no matter
how smart he or she is can handle these
kinds of information
even if they sit all day and only read
the literature instead of treating
patients
the that that's not the only thing that
grows exponentially with time the other
thing that grows is the amount of
information within the patient's record
so uh when we had paper records
once in a while we put everything in the
archive
now everything is digital once it exists
it stays forever and the information
accumulates really fast and for a
specific medical decision decision uh in
this year maybe a specific lab test that
was recorded 13 years ago is relevant
for a specific medical decision that i
need to make today
the chances that i'll know and remember
that piece of information when i need to
make this decision crossing it with all
the literature that we just saw is is
pretty slim
and this is not just for one medical
condition at a time a lot of patients
are suffering from multiple medical
conditions
and this statistics from clarity
actually shows that after the age of 45
more than half of the population have at
least one chronic conditions and as age
increases this rapidly increases to many
many chronic conditions
and luckily
the population
is aging because we have better life
expectancy so we have many many more of
these individuals
with multi
comorbidities to take care of and all
these
factors go into a situation in which we
have pressing and burning issues in
health care the first is that
the ideal care compared to what we would
expect with the up-to-date literature
and all the information from the
patient's records and all of his or hers
condition medical conditions
is getting further from the ideal
because the deal is almost unachievable
and the second thing that happens is
when we try to handle all of these
conditions and all of this information
and all this overload it's getting
harder and harder to
focus on preventive care because we
focus on what's already happening
so like
lifting our heads above the water and
looking into the future and asking
ourselves what we should try to prevent
uh which outcomes we should prevent for
any patient becomes uh harder and harder
and
when we think about it it's not one
condition for for a specific patient
that is now healthy
it's dozens of conditions or hundreds of
conditions and which one should we focus
on
so that means that our ability to focus
on preventive care uh is decreasing over
time
but we think that we can do something
about it
and if you won't do anything about it
we'll have a problem and we can't just
go on the way we did healthcare until
now we need to change something
fundamental in the way we're giving
healthcare and i can tell you that the
way we give healthcare as opposed to
other
areas in life
has not changed dramatically in recent
in in recent years or decades it's
pretty much the same
but we think that now we have the
opportunity to really uh bring in some
new changes that could dramatically
change the situation and this these
changes could be smart use of data and
quantitative models in order to really
improve patients care
so let's start with the first
problem that we saw the ability to focus
on preventive care preventive care is
the most effective care
uh it's the cheapest it's it doesn't
have side effects usually uh it doesn't
prolong the patient's life
in a few years or months it can bring
them years of healthy living
and it's really the care that we want to
provide but how can we try to prevent
numerous chronic conditions from
happening in the future when we don't
know on which patients to focus and on
what conditions to focus and here is
where predictive models can really help
us because predictive models
can take
many many many data points from within
those medical records that we've
discussed and try to integrate them
together
into a prediction that identifies
specific subgroups that are at a high
risk for deteriorating towards a
specific condition in the future and
this could be done
separately for different conditions
identifying different populations for
intervention
so this this
potentially
could be done using those thousands of
pieces of information but the human mind
is not very effective in such tasks
not even the doctor's minds and uh if
you look at this picture uh i imagine
that most of you are trying to find
waldo by now and maybe some of you found
one or two but if we ask a computer to
do this
it happens in a split of a second and
with uh full accuracy and we don't even
have to uh take any effort so we think
that when we try to
look at patterns and
many many many
data points and
identify patients that are prone to
deteriorate in the future
prediction models and ai can really help
us do it and let's look at one example
and dive a bit into it so hepatitis c
hepatitis c is a condition caused by a
virus
called hepatitis c
which infects the liver and is
considered to be the first cause the
number one cause of of liver cancer and
liver transplants in the u.s
this is a virus that can be contracted
in several manners but the thing about
this virus is that once someone
contracts it they could become silent
carriers of this virus and then over
many many years their liver gradually
deteriorates
until one day they can get into liver
failure and knee transplant or either
develop liver cancer
so this is something that we really want
to treat but um unfortunately
until not so many years ago the
treatments were pretty horrible they had
horrible side effects that were compared
to chemotherapy
they were giving through injections and
only 50 of those who took these
medications actually recovered from the
virus
and a few years ago something that is
really no short of a miracle in modern
medicine happened and new diseases and
new medications
were actually identified and developed
to to cure hepatitis c these new
medications are given
through pills they don't have almost any
side effects
and their cure rate is over 95 percent
sometimes even more over 98
so amazing treatment and this brought
the notion that maybe
this disease had been can be eliminated
from the world and the who basically
created a plan of how this disease will
be eliminated by 2030.
the problem is that only 50
of the individuals that are chronic
carriers of this condition
are aware of that and 50 percent are
what's called silent carriers and no one
really knows that they're sick so in
order to identify these individuals we
need to screen them and the the who asks
uh each country in the world to come up
with a screening plan to identify uh hcv
htv's hepatitis c virus hcv patients
that are
silent carriers and could be treated and
and basically cure their drivers
so this happened in israel as well and
the group of experts basically sat and
identified the most
fundamental risk factors for
being a silent carrier of hepatitis c
and those uh
factors included three being a former
resident of a country in which htv is
endemic
uh people who receive blood products
prior to 1992 the year that they've
started screening blood products for
hepatitis c and iv uh drug users uh
because that's one of the ways this
virus is transmitted and basically
being computer science
crowd at least part of the crowd this
could be plotted as a decision tree it's
an algorithm but this decision tree is a
very very simplified decision tree with
only one split
of either you belong to group a b or c
then you should be screened otherwise
you should not be screened
so most of the population will not be
screened and their probability of being
infected is indeed very small but a
pretty pretty substantial part of the
population should be screened 10 in this
case
and their probability is is higher but
still pretty small
and this begs the question can we do
better with all this information and all
with all these new models that we have
and in order to answer that question
we took a retrospective cohort of over
300
000 individuals who were not screened
for hepatitis c until the year 2010
and we
checked which of these patients will be
tested in the future and what happens to
them and we found that
0.5
of those who are tested actually
are found to be silent carriers of
hepatitis c active carriers that should
be treated
and now we can basically do what we want
to
in order to use of all of these data to
cross many many many from data points
regarding
lab results diagnosis medications
whatever you can think about from the
patient's record with the outcome of
interest
put it into a machine and try to come up
with a model that will identify patients
who are very prone to be tested positive
if they were to be tested and this is
what we got in the first iteration this
is again a decision tree but it's much i
think you will agree that it's much more
sophisticated than the decision tree
that we initially had
and it's a white box model so it has the
advantage that we can actually see what
happens in each node and understand why
each patient received a recommendation
to be tested
these are the red nodes or not as that
these are the blue nodes and if we
enlarge
some of it
to be able to read
some of the variables you can see that
the first splitting nodes are actually
the those that were identified by the
experts as the most uh uh relevant
criteria for screening
so it means that something
logical is happening here we it seems
like we can trust this process because
i can tell you that medicine is not
really used to using
such models usually
and it takes a leap of faith in order to
trust this kind of model to
use variables that are not listed in the
medical literature in the medical
textbooks as risk factors for risk
factors for hepatitis c
and we can take another leap of faith
and not use this white box model of a
single decision tree even if it's more
sophisticated than the original decision
tree we can actually
grow many many such trees in this case
43 trees using what's called boosting
decision trees algorithms extgbus in
this case and then each patient
basically travels throughout all of
these trees simultaneously and getting
an even more accurate prediction than
the single decision tree
so let's see how it works and if it
works and if it's it's worth all the
hassle so we said that we have a
prevalence of 0.5
uh in individuals that are currently
silent hcv carriers and we want to
identify these
and
in order to do that we are willing to do
some screening
and let's say that our
prediction model told us to screen 6.6
of this population
so if the model was a random model
theoretically we would expect to find
six point six percent of those of this
red slice right if it's completely
random so we will find six point six
percent of this red slice but the
algorithm is obviously not random and
it's effective and it turns out that the
overlap between the yellow slice of the
screening and the red slice of the true
positives is very uh large and even
though we screen only 6.6 of the
population we can actually identify
72 percent of the silent carriers
and that's something that seems very
effective and
worthwhile
uh and just a note regarding this
process of screening so screening is
done
for many conditions
breast cancer colorectal cancer
you all know it because it will be
relevant to all of you at some point in
life and you should know that many of
these decisions in medicine are
basically those simplified decision
trees which we could maybe call decision
stumps because trees is maybe
like overstating it
but this process of gradually increasing
the decision complexity
towards decision trees that are more
complicated and eventually towards
forests of trees
seems very logical but it's something
that the medical community needs to
grow accustomed to and gradually
trust and this is the kind of thing that
we're trying to put into uh daily
healthcare in clelit and we think that
it's much more effective and if we
address the the
challenges that we've started with of
how
healthcare systems are basically
overburdened today
these kinds of models can really help us
to identify the very specific subgroup
of patients for which the preventive
care preventive measures will be very
very very effective and uh
again this is the kind of care that we
really want to practice
so with that uh we can't not talk about
kovin so at the march
of 2020 uh the beginning of the kovit
pandemic um
in israel that took took a few months
until he got to to western countries
uh policy makers include basically came
to us and said
you know how to do all these prediction
models we really want you to help us
identify or evaluate individuals risks
for severe kobe 19
because we think it will be effective
towards all these proactive measures
that we want to take in order to defend
these uh populations that are at high
risk uh the only problem was that we
didn't have kobe 19 data in israel at
the time and we just discussed how
basically what the computers are good at
doing
is taking
a lot of data points and crossing them
with a specific outcome in order to
identify a pattern but here we don't
have the outcome so what do we do so we
won't get into
detail but as a very high level process
what we did is basically to create a
predictor
for a different outcome but a related
outcome or at least we thought that
physiologically it's a related outcome
and that outcome was severe respiratory
infection
illness so we thought that if we
identify patients who are prone to these
conditions maybe we can try to transform
this predictor later to be some kind of
a pro kobe 19 predictor and it actually
made a lot of sense because we saw that
the
this predictor
came up with features that are very
relevant and make sense medically and
then basically what we wanted to do is
to adjust these prediction outputs to
specific case fatality rates of kobe 19
that came from china in those early days
and the way we did it is through uh some
joint work with people who sit here in
the crowd
of multi-calibration which is
an algorithm taken from the fairness
domain but it actually came in uh pretty
handy in this situation to translate
this initial predictor into a kovi 19
predictor a few months later we we
changed that predictor to to train
specifically kovi 19 data because we had
that on the time but this predictor
actually was pretty useful in the in the
few first few months of the pandemic in
israel
just to uh
convince you that it actually works so
some statistics about its effect uh how
its performance so we basically defined
two
wrist groups of the cladding population
one is the very high risk group and the
second is the high risk group so the
first
market in red here
consisted of only eight percent of the
population
but was able to identify seventy-three
percent of those who ended up
deteriorating if they contracted uh
source code two
and
the high-risk group consisted of of 15
of the population but was able to
identify more than 90
of those who will deteriorate so now we
have a group that we can uh
very effectively uh manage and try to
prevent the condition and maybe treat it
better so let's see what we did for
prevention
so in the very few
first few weeks after we developed this
predictor uh 200 000 individuals were
the very high risk group
actually received personal phone calls
from their clinics and care providers
which they know telling them how they
should be careful of this new disease
that they don't know and what what
should they do
the high risk group and the very high
risk group also received
sms messages with personalized
content regarding their high risk and
how they should uh try to avoid this
disease and also they were prioritized
for some home accessible services such
as uh delivery of medications to the
home instead of to uh going to
pharmacies
once patients were unfortunately uh
infected with the source cove too
patients that were defined at the very
high risk group
even if they were triage to be treated
at home were actually favored to go into
inpatient care because
we thought that it could help prevent
their deterioration and more recently
actually in the very in last month when
not only kovi 19 vaccines got into our
arsenal of treatments but also
treatments uh both given both through
injections and
through uh pills to prevent the duration
once the patient was infected
were also prioritized on a daily basis
through these kinds of models so every
morning we would distribute lists to
physicians throughout cleli throughout
israel stating these are the patients
that were infected yesterday
these are the ones in the highest risk
please proactively call them and invite
them to to receive the medication
if it was
through injections or
not invite them actually go to their
house and give them their injections or
send the ps2 to their house and explain
how they should use uh the medications
so uh again these kinds of prediction
models once they stratify the population
help us be much more effective and be
much more um
accurate in the efforts that we do make
to prevent
conditions and these models throughout
the last two years were constantly
translated into simplified models for
the public use so these are point-based
models that are obviously a bit less
accurate than the more expressive models
but could be used by each page each
patient to calculate their uh risk count
and understand why they are defined to
be at specific risk groups and what's
the implications this model is actually
very
it's actually was published and not
published published within it in the
last couple of weeks because it's the
first model that we've integrated uh
that actually has uh factors of
protective factors and not only risk
factors uh giving your vaccination at
the time sense that aspects of
vaccination and whether or not you were
previously infected
so again each patient can calculate
their own risk count on the left and
then i know
uh which so this is for internal use if
you want different cutoffs for different
interventions based on the amount of
resources that we have but then we know
how many of those uh patients we
identified to be uh at high risk and
how many of these if they will contract
the disease will actually deteriorate uh
and we see uh the trend the very clear
trend based on the amount of plants
so these kinds of of models we talked
about two of these uh we have many more
that are actually informing care on a
daily basis trying to make it more
preventive as we discussed but each of
these the implementation of each of
these is basically an appeal struggle
because the emr system the electronical
medical records are legacy system it's
very hard to change them it's very hard
to bring these kinds of of outputs to
the point of care at the right time for
the physicians and uh basically in the
last year or so what we're trying to do
is to create platforms that will break
this world of integration and
implementation and we create this
platform cpi which stands for clearly
proactive prevention in
proactive preventive interventions and
this is basically a patient management
platform to promote this proactive and
personalized care
the way that it's done is that basically
each physician receives intervention
list from multiple conditions
for example now we're seeing a list for
the prevention of
osteoporotic fractures this list is
prioritized based on the predicted risk
of deteriorating towards that specific
medical condition
and physician actually gets two hours a
week which is a like protected time in
their calendar to
do these proactive interventions not
wait for the physicians to go through
the door but actually uh
getting to to them and this is also done
in holistic matter not considering each
medical condition separately but
considering multiple such conditions
simultaneously
and for each patient considering their
specific predicted risk towards
different kinds of medical conditions
so we talked about the ability to focus
on preventive care and how we can help
these uh
this task through quantitative models
but we also talked about the problem and
the the very large challenge that we
have uh with the gaps in care that are
starting to
increase over time
with the care patients actually receive
compared to the ideal care
that should be given according to the up
to date the most up-to-date literature
that no one can really keep up with
and this is a problem throughout the
world
and here
again data can come into our health and
we can utilize data in order to narrow
these gaps in care how can we do that we
can take expert physicians the expert
best expert physicians in each specific
domain and basically try to create
clinical pathways
for the entire
process of
screening uh follow-up treatment of
patients in that condition and these
pathways can be very very very detailed
uh
to the degree of detail that corresponds
to the most up-to-date medical
literature and then basically we can
take
patients and make them travel through
these pathways and gather their
personalized recommendations every night
automatically for the entire uh
healthcare system so imagine 4.7 million
individuals traveling throughout these
very little pathways for multiple
conditions every night collecting the
most up-to-date recommendations so these
will be given tomorrow morning for the
physicians to try to make their care
more close to the ideal care that they
should receive and these kinds of
outputs also go into such platforms so
now we look at a specific record for a
specific patient
showing all of the relevant information
for a specific medical condition and all
of the specific personalized
recommendation
for laboratory tests referrals treatment
and additional recommendations for that
specific condition for that specific
patient
and
basically it translates to
that primary care physician that used to
sit alone in the clinic
so imagine that now behind
this physician's back we have the most
up-to-date to the most expert
cardiologist that was identified that
was chosen by the med but from the
entire medical system as the one that
should define these guidelines and the
most
expert endocrinologist and the most
expert neurologist and the most
expensive clinical pharmacist
true story because these are the kind of
kinds of experts that we have for this
system right now and now she's not
sitting alone anymore now she has behind
her back the best medical advice for a
specific patient uh personalized and
up-to-date and with that
we think that we can make the care
better we can make it more accurate
there are these gaps that we talked
about we can make it more proactive
because we can focus through prediction
models on the right patients we can
integrate all these information into
specific platforms of information and to
integrate it into the point of care at
the right time for the right patient
and with that maybe we can help these
very burning and pressing issues we have
in healthcare and with that
we'll finish
[Applause]
thank you for voting for an amazing talk
and also for all your work
and um
questions for the
person
the amazing workforce thank you
so one question is for your streamline
how do you evaluate
i would think that will work but you
still need
how do you evaluate
the this system uh what's the like the
control in a way the intervention
or
with all this new system of clinical
aids okay so so it's a very good uh
question
the the holy grail is what's called the
learning healthcare system that
integrates these kinds of tools and
continuously
measures how they are effective so they
could keep upgrade and only keep up keep
the the interventions that are most
effective
this is the holy grail and it's called
the holy grail for a reason and there
is almost no healthcare system that gets
to that yet for us this is very new so i
just showed you the most up-to-date
things that we do we really hope that in
the next couple of years we'll be seeing
uh results and we could uh use both
causal
analysis in order to see the effects
that these interventions took but also
uh
maybe use some more sophisticated
manners and specifically for things like
the htv screening it's it's easier
because we can see how many patients we
send uh to be screened based on the
algorithm and how many of them uh
basically turn out positive and that's
the most easiest case that we have
because we have the answer really
readily available within a few days or
weeks
a lot of the conditions are very chronic
in nature so the prediction will be for
10 years at the time so it takes time to
know whether we got it right or wrong
it's it's more of a chronic nature
of a thing so we need to be patient and
we know that we have to measure uh
because that's the holy grail and we
really want to do it appropriately but
we're the beginning of the process
does it make sense to ask patient
satisfaction as a surrogate or proxy
so it's a question it's a good question
whether uh patients will uh know about
this system how many physicians so some
physicians uh the the system is now
starting to be implemented so some
physicians don't tell us with the right
patients they actually uh turn their
screen and share the the outputs
together with them and they can see it i
imagine that in many of the cases that's
not the case uh it's it can never be 100
percent uh accurate
it's a decision support system it's not
a decision maker the data is never 100
accurate we can never uh replace the the
physician judgment so it's basically
for the use of physicians and not
directly to patients
but
in cases where the outputs will reach
the patients it's really interesting too
thank you
um thank you very much both were really
interesting talks and i have questions
to both of you
uh so to noah um
and this follows up on bin's question
about evaluating like you said this is a
recommendation it's not forced
i have a former student who did some
research with a
algorithm that helped managers and call
centers determine who to interview for a
job
and those managers that followed the
recommendation they ended up
interviewing better people than those
who didn't
now here you have experts and it would
be interesting to see if those who don't
follow the advice
are actually better at making decisions
or worsening decisions and if there's
some heterogeneity i don't know if
you've looked at that but that would be
quite interesting so it is it's it's a
brilliant endear and actually a lot of
the things that could be more uh readily
available for for evaluation is the
adherence to recommendations and not the
long-term outcomes
so that's something that we'll
definitely uh mean to follow to follow
up with and we hope that they will
adhere but actually it's all very in the
very few months of deployment and it's
gradual deployment so it will take some
time uh but
you really hope to see eye adherance and
to understand for those who do not hear
why is it that they're better physicians
than they know better do they think that
they know better but they don't really
know better um
or just they don't have the time and
to know him uh when
you talked about the um
uh indirect effects right
uh now obviously like you said you're
making assumptions in the lack of an rct
one question about that data is whether
the parents were vaccinated
are also behaving differently in ways
that you can't measure
so for example
parents who choose to get vaccinated
they may be more risk-averse
as such at home they may impl employ
more uh you know like separation when
when someone gets sick they put them in
a separate room whereas parents who
don't get vaccinated they just are more
cavalier about it
so in what way do you know or are you
confident i guess you can't know that
indeed you're able to control for these
idiosyncratic preferences
so
behavioral factors are very
serious potential confounders for
vaccine effectiveness this is
nonetheless there is extensive rich
literature about it there is no easy way
to deal with it because we don't
directly measure behavioral tendencies
however we can use surrogates so for
example we adjust for
a previous vaccination for example
influenza vaccinations we adjust for how
many times a person goes to see their
general physician which is a surrogate
for health seeking behavior you can't
there is always going to be residual
confounding it's unavoidable but we
think you can capture a lot of it and
you can you can use things like negative
control outcomes to know that there is
no disaster you didn't miss something
horribly big
well i really enjoyed the talk it was
very inspiring um i was wondering did
you guys think about building in um also
uh recommendations for like uh
proactively
collecting data that would help
your data set be more um
like maybe miss things that you didn't
see so i think right now
you talked about you know using the
machine learning techniques that kind of
fit what you're seeing in the data set
for example like the hcv like you
there's a five percent that was detect
you know that that was detected but
there could have been a different
subpopulation that just happened to be
less tested because of the policy that
was used to gather the data and um
and that would not be able to be
detected by the ml method so i was
wondering if you guys thought about the
aspect of like
complementing the data in the active way
so the answer is yes um less less in the
way that you refer to like sending uh
patients for uh screening for when we
don't have a good reason just to see to
get a better representation of the of
the population and it's different
suburbs
but more in terms of because it's it's
just logistically very hard and very
expensive and as we said health care
systems and
including trade but all of the
healthcare systems are very highly
burdened as it is
but we really want to augment the data
with things outside of the medical
record so we know that the medical
record has
specific types of data and as we see
that it is fortunate to be very rich in
data uh and but still this kind of data
is
not very uh online
so we have lab tests that are done every
few years or every few months
we have some conditions that are being
recorded some consultations some
complaints but we have a lot of
iot devices today to collect many many
more
data points we really want to be able to
create infrastructures in which we can
suggest patients to use these and and
ask them if they're willing to
contribute this kind of data in order to
create uh models that are maybe more
online in nature and are more granular
in data
i can also tell you that we're trying to
do this uh not only to the center but
sensors but also through for example
imaging so for example a lot of patients
are undergoing ct scans for all sorts of
reasons these ct scans get a glimpse
into your body and you can collect a lot
of information from that ct scan but
basically today most of the uh reports
basically just say
whether they found something very major
or whether for the specific complaint
that the city was done for they found
something or not but if a patient is
being screened for whatever uh for a
city and that city happened to to uh
take a glimpse of their heart we can see
whether they have what's called uh
calcium
uh
it's called the calcium score whether
they have calcium deposits in their
coronary arteries and that's a major
risk factor for cardiovascular diseases
more than any risk factor that you know
like hypertension or cholesterol or
whatever because that's like the end
point so even if that patient did not
have yet a heart attack we know
something very substantial that now is
currently not used by anyone so we're
trying to integrate ai system that go
through these scans to find these
opportunistic
findings and then integrate these
opportunistic findings into these kinds
of system in order to inform the the
physician better throughout all of the
information that we can collect so all
of these gathering new types of data and
new types of information is definitely
something that we're trying to do but
it's much harder and it takes time
compared to using what we already have
and also maybe um since we spend a lot
of time today thinking about like
algorithmic fairness was that something
that you guys have thought about when
designing these systems or if we're
aware of
looking at you know if the
current
health care procedures are maybe not
currently fair and whether the system
would exacerbate that
so we can so the answer is yes because
we are fortunate to work with some of
these guys here um
but it's it's we can spend our
discussing it it's not that
straightforward in medicine because in
medicine many of the
factors that are considered protective
variables are actually things that we
can't ignore so uh sex and sometimes
race is a big issue whether it's it's a
genetic marker or something that is
biologically
marker of relevant utility uh but it's
so it's things that we need to consider
and i think uh guys showed this morning
how we can improve models through these
kinds of
algorithm but it's not that
straightforward as indifferent and
domains like hiring someone for our job
which is real it's obvious that sex is
not should not affect it if we're trying
to um
think about osoprotic fractures
obviously sex is something that's
obviously very important because females
are much more prone so the answer is yes
but but the long answer is that it's
complicated
is there somebody else
uh what you said about the fact that we
cannot digest all this information
coming our way you know the papers the
records and so forth which sort of
indicates
also as a secondary thing
that people who are more
literate or that fall in literature more
or maybe
[Music]
they are close to someone uh you know i
think about israeli system there's
always someone you know who knows
someone and and they tell you what to do
right so people are more connected to
the sources of knowledge
i would assume are better treated or
because they kind of follow their own
they take things matter in their own
hands speaking of fairness
i wonder if there's any model that
i know that in financial things they
have actually records that if you know
you sort of do investments as people
close to you tell you what to do so if
you are asking your local butcher or how
to invest versus someone
who works in wall street there'll be
different outcomes
it's very very true no i'm sure the
graph that that basically
illustrates that for kobe 19 vaccines
right because the the
populations with the higher
socioeconomic status get more vaccines
even though the healthcare system in
israel is public everyone can get it
freely and very are very encouraged to
get it still some get it more and and if
it's not
is related to to health care disparities
um
being a public health care system uh
throughout the years [ __ ] implemented a
lot of of narrowing the gaps kind of
interventions and these were very
effective in narrowing gaps
for
i would say processes like getting
mammographies and getting a
colorectal cancer screening
tests
they are less
so there are still gaps in in the more
hard outcomes of the actual um
adherence not just to the process but
for the outcome measures so for example
uh for uh things like how well you are
uh with your controlling your diabetes
which is harder than just taking a
screen we still see some gaps and we're
the the health the the entire health
care ins
system in israel is based on like the
the opening sentence of the public
health law is that this law is based on
uh values of equality and and and things
like that so the whole system is very
geared towards narrowing these gaps but
unfortunately they still exist and even
for the life expectancy statistics you
can still see some
sadly some differences between subgroups
in the israeli population and and in
dayton it's not an israeli kind of thing
it's in it's in the entire world but we
do try very hard to narrow it but
interestingly it seems to me that more
information like widen it rather than
narrow it
but not that
you see what i'm saying
more information available to people in
some groups
even though the intention is good
uh the outcome interestingly i think
will probably widen the gap rather than
the other way
so
obviously uh and healthcare literacy is
something that's directly affected i
think it's it's uh it's a given that
these kinds of systems when they bring
the expert's opinion to the periphery
and make it available as it is for
someone who sits in the center of israel
i hope will help narrow these kinds of
gaps but
there is no magic cure to such things
it's a lot of hard work and so
equitability is another outcome that
needs to be evaluated
for these interventions and i i give it
more i think it will it will improve the
equitability of the healthcare system
but definitely something that deserves
to be studied as part of this
intervention one thing that is clearly
equitable is the mistakes
immortality are equitable across
so my last question is
what you mentioned about the ct scan
doctors say only take because they care
about my knee and then they find
something in like the egg wouldn't find
something
in my heart so this is kind of against
the western medicine philosophy very
comparable
compartmentized
kind of philosophy the food doctor
doesn't care about me the needle doesn't
care about the heart do you think the ai
approach because access
as a global information will help them
magically stab them to move more like a
holistic philosophy
so i think that once we take these
holistic approaches and the data-driven
approaches as the example so that we've
had with the ct so if they will scan
your knee they will not know anything
about your heart but if they scan
something in your lungs this is closer
they will see something and could use it
so and and as you see these these kinds
of systems integrate many medical
collisions together and many medical
many medical experts together so i think
the answer would be yes but
to be proven
thank you
so i think it's five o'clock and thank
you very much for a fascinating talk and
for coming to talk to us thank you
you